I actually have this girl
and she just recently switched into the Boston Latin Academy
I think she tested into this school
and in the beginning,
she was having a really hard time
with the math and she felt so behind and she was
feeling a little bit discouraged.
One week after I had been working with her she came in
and she pulled out this quiz
and she said “Hannah, look at this I got a one hundred.”
so that was just so exciting
to see that our work had a
positive impact
and you never really realize how much you
didn't know that something about something that you thought was familiar to you
until you actually have to you explain it to someone
else and you think “Oh, what was the point of this again?”
I think I just learned a lot. You learn so much by
Teaching.
I think that’s just the philosophy that
I had going through this whole experience.
I have been a mentor at the Ed portal and what
that means is essentially I go in once
a week
for about four hours and I went on Thursdays
which was really great because I got to do
one-on-ones and a project they call “Science Club”.
So one on one basically, you spent forty
minutes
with a student and they can be
age…I think the youngest one-on-one
was fourth grade and so fourth grade through
high school and basically this session is
tailored toward whatever the student likes.
Some students want to do experiments the whole
Time, some students just bring their homework
and we'll sit and do their homework and basically
the mentor is just there to be a resource, to
be a problem solver. So, you know, I have done my
homework with students you know we will both just sit there.
It is just the space for them to come and
be able to do their work. Other students, especially
high school students, are sort of looking
for advice, so sometimes I just want to sit,
and chat.
So the one-on-one mentoring is so different
it just, you know, it goes from student to student.
I've been focusing on the science mentoring
aspect
so we did a lot of manly a lot of really exciting
things like exploding various
objects like we would exploded foam canisters
with the alka-seltzer rockets and we'd let
them combine pretty basic things like vinegar and baking soda
and let them see the explosion.
It was just really great to sort of introduce all
these aspects of science to these young children
because
I remember being their age and my first experiences
with science was a similar it was just some a mentor
of mine who came and  showed me all these
different aspects of in scientific research
and experiments
and from there I just became so inspired
in science
and so I felt my goal in these one on one
was to sort of
introduce that same
spirit of science in these young children
because I think it's very important that they
realized science is all around them and they can definitely explore science using just what they
have.